hi guys it's Alvin and I love grilled
cheese I think it's an amazing comfort
food and we actually made a 20-pound
grilled cheese on our tasty show making
a bake which was pretty fun my friend
Annie who's the producer in this video
sent me over 11 grilled cheese hacks to
try and make a grilled cheese and they
look really fun so I'm excited to try
them out my ideal grilled cheese is two
slices of bread at least two kinds of
cheese toasted in butter until both
sides are evenly golden brown and the
inside is nice gooey and melty you can't
really go wrong with that okay so the
first tack is to use a bakery style
thicker kind of loaf cut of bread
I think this will give the grilled
cheese a nice texture and make it better
to eat and have it be more interesting I
like this kind of bread second act is to
toast the inside of the bread before
actually toasting the outside as you
would normally I think the goal here is
to get a nice crispy texture I'm
actually really excited to try this
because I want that like extra crispy
crunch at the end and we I guess we
won't know until the whole sandwich is
done okay so the next hack is to rub a
clove of garlic under the bread after
it's cooked I'm excited about this one
too because anything is I don't have to
chop up garlic to make my grilled cheese
have a Karluk flavor which is really
nice
and I feel like it's just gonna be more
of a nice garlic flavor rather than just
like chunks it smells great so the next
hack is to use multiple cheeses to
provide a wide range of texture flavor
melting this all that good stuff on the
internet I read that three to five is
great so obviously I chose five okay so
here are the five cheese's there's
cheddar which is your classic yellow
names just checking just a nice cheese
to have this is Greer which i think is
actually one of the best cheeses and
grilled cheese because even though it's
like super strong and maybe funky before
it's cooked
I think after it's cooked it's sweet and
mellow and really good which is nice
parmesan cuz parmesan just is just
really good at general lot some
provolone for a different kind of more
mild flavor and it adds that kind of
melt eNOS in chewiness and when stir
this cheese which has that signature
kind of tiger stripe outline it's also
really melty and really good
so the next hack is to shred the cheese
into shreds rather than just kind of
cutting them in a slices or blocks of a
cheese grater here it's not a full one
but hopefully it's kind of work I think
the idea here is to kind of make the
cheese more uniform when it melts so you
don't have pockets of unmelted cheese
and pockets of overcooked cheese so I
think this makes total sense
the next hack is to spread Mayo instead
of butter onto the bread before cooking
I actually heard a lot about this one
I've never tried in real life so really
excited to try it I'm not sure how it's
going to taste in theory it makes sense
because Mayo has like eggs and oil and
that old could caramelize nicely but
I'll have to try before I see if it's
better than butter okay I think it's
time to assemble the sandwich so I want
to start with the shredded so it can
kind of fill these holes and not spill
everywhere actually the shredding is a
really good idea because I think with a
bread like this it really does kind of
like stay in there more because of all
the big holes we just talked about so
it's almost like the two hacks are
working in conjunction
the next hack is to actually cook the
grilled cheese separately in two
different pans I'm not sure this is
gonna be worth the trouble because you
have to get another pan dirty and like
when you put them together there's a
chance it could spill but apparently it
helps the cheese melt faster I'm gonna
try and see this is actually worth the
trouble
yeah apparently the grilled cheese isn't
done until the cheese starts oozing and
well oh yeah it's [ __ ] it's definitely
losing so this is the grilled cheese
kind of has all the hacks Mayo crust
thick bread the multiple cheeses the
shredded I'm excited to eat this because
I just want to know which ones were
actually worth it big red is nice as
it's nice and chewy kind of like I
thought it absorbs all that cheese into
the hole it is great so the pre toasting
hack I don't think it made a difference
just because I couldn't tell that the
inside was toasted it's not like it was
extra crunchy the garlic hack was kind
of fun and it makes sense in theory but
honestly I didn't really taste it at
then so probably not worth it I like the
multiple cheese hang I think it makes a
lot of sense I think if you have a lot
of cheeses it's a lot of flavor
you don't miss the mail which is nice I
couldn't tell the mail crust I don't
know why the two pans thing is a thing
pretty good pretty good pretty good rope
cheese another couple go-sees hacks that
I want to try they're really cool so I
want to show you guys what they are okay
so I have two sandwiches that I just
made exactly like the other one this one
we're actually gonna cook with brown
butter in the pan herb sounds really
good and this one we're actually gonna
try technique I saw online from chef Jon
from food wishes he actually uses like
actual cheese on the outside and it
cooks in the pan and it gives it a
really nice crust I'm really excited for
that I really like brown butter I used
it in a lot of baked goods like cookies
and stuff but I think it's just an
amazing thing that we're all cuz you get
so much flavor from browning butter or a
big bowl of going
making sure the bread can get all of
that great stuff that we just work
really hard to make it probably exists
online but I like the idea of it is to
actually put some honey on the bread as
it caramelizes so that when it's almost
done honey you can almost act as another
like thin layer caramelize sugar that
gives it extra crunchy all right guys
this is it oh my god look at this
this beautiful honey brown butter glaze
specific grilled cheese the honey and
the brown butter like absolute
GameChanger like it's sweet its crusty
it's great there's so much flavor it
balances with it she's so well I mean I
like putting honey and brown butter and
things but grilled cheese like it might
sound we're to put something sweet but
the crust and the flavor is with the
cheese it's amazing old boy Gus okay so
the last tack is to cook sandwich but
instead of using butter stuff in the pan
we're gonna use actual cheese I think
the idea is to get this cheese to brown
up and then stick to this as a crust so
it's like almost like an inside-out
grilled cheese um but if chef Jon
through bushes did it and it works and I
trust him because he is the og master so
we'll see how it goes okay if I mess
this up it'll probably because it's my
technique but I'll do my best to try to
get to where the hack is supposed to be
[Music]
okay this is the third one the
inside-out grilled cheese I guess it's
looks really greasy yeah I think is just
so much cheese that I mean maybe I just
put too much in the middle or put too
much overall but see how it tastes
it's really sharp and strong this
involves salt you love that then I think
is the perfect hand for you
regal too salty a little too greasy my
roommate loves cheese so huh my good
mister but I don't think I can take more
than a couple bites of this one so those
were the 11 hacks to make grilled cheese
my favorite three the first one's got to
be the sourdough bread or any sort of
thick-cut bread a lot of texture a lot
of flavor I think it's way better than
like the store-bought sandwich white
bread but there's nothing wrong with
that as well
my second favorite hack is definitely
the multiple cheeses I think it's great
to have a lot but obviously you can make
it with one or two it'll still be
awesome and the third one I really got
to give it to the honey one like that
one was so cool I love sweet and savory
and I loved glazing a lot of things in
honey so having that extra shine extra
crust that glistening crackle II sort of
texture that isn't just bread it's
really good hopefully you guys enjoy
making your grilled cheeses and I'm
gonna go exercise a lot now that piece
[Music]